what is this jamie from 2011 man fights
lion
to boost egypt tourism what come on
yeah come on this is real he's sitting
in there with a little plastic lawn
chair
he's got a shield he's got a spear the
shield is shady as [ __ ] what in the [ __ ]
dude hell yeah not a lot of room either
not a giant lion but
is this this actually happened
this is 100 live like recorded videos on
cbs news
jesus christ this guy get jacked or what
and this isn't that's not showing it
it must not have been a long fight and
it was probably subdued
oh yeah it's obviously happening
if this guy recorded then it's probably
happening
he had to do like a two minutes or
something with it i bet yeah the line
seems fine
he's gonna climb on top i win he's
already i am the winner
yeah he's gonna do like a [ __ ] cage
drop drop down on that line
imagine that the balls you would have to
leap down with a spear and drive it
through the lion's brain
from the top rope
play spray all over the place you could
do it
someone would do it if that dummy got in
there with that lion you
you could definitely get if you gave
someone a million dollars yeah he gave
them a shield and a sword
and an armor give him some armor not all
armor
not your neck yeah that counts to be
free you can pick the neck of the loin
piece
that line would leap on you so fast your
sword to be knocked out of your hand it
would just
crush your [ __ ] head with its teeth
but one man would do it
yeah one man would win
maybe the the mountain from game of
thrones the giant dude yeah
give that guy like a battle axe like a
[ __ ]
85 pound axe
who would do it in ufc who would who do
you think could win
and it's not saying that they're the
greatest or they're the best but who
could do that
it would have to be the biggest guys it
would have to be like the heavyweight
champ it would have to be like stipe
miocic or francis and gano or someone
giant
who'd have to be a big powerful person
because you'd have to be able to swing
that [ __ ] sword fast
and you have to be able to take a hit
from a 500 pound cat
you're probably gonna get [ __ ] up
either way though you need one you bet
you have to be able to take one good hit
like you're gonna take one good hit
i just feel like you're just gonna get
[ __ ] up i just don't think you have a
chance
there's a lot of debates about this when
i was reading it earlier of course
people there's a lot of people just as
stupid as me and theo
i think the line wouldn't have a good
technique or [ __ ] it up
it doesn't matter if it has good
technique the physical power
of a lion is just so overwhelming i
don't i just don't think
people understand how much force it can
generate how quickly it can move
how quickly he could get you it'd be it
would just [ __ ] spramble on you
it would be on you so fast dude there's
a video
hilarious video of a bunch of dudes
running away from tiny in comparison
a leopard is what 150 pounds or
something like that and these [ __ ]
people
are running left and right and this
thing's coming after them and you
realize like oh my god
like look at this this guy running now
watch the leopard take the corner
look just look at he slides the leopard
is going so fast it's running on the
walls on the top
like the middle of the wall above his
[ __ ] head
watch how as he starts running forward
and the leopard comes into the picture
the leopard is literally running on a
vertical wall like watch this watch when
it comes around the corner
look at this it's running on the wall
it's got so much power that it's running
on the side of the wall like you can't
even imagine the kind of
physical speed and strength that that
thing has in its body
it's bouncing from the side of the wall
to the other side of the wall
and just trying to get some traction so
it could get a hold of your [ __ ] ass
damn can't wait to get a hold of your
[ __ ] ass you don't have a chance at
that thing
that's a fraction of the size of a lion
just a fraction right [ __ ] man oh
jesus christ got loose in a school oh
god no this is a video game isn't it
look at it climb over the top of that
fence like it ain't [ __ ]
it's one of those video games on the
dark web i think
middle school leopard dude you find that
thing you just gotta shoot it
you just gotta shoot it there's not much
you could do oh it's [ __ ] this dude
up
oh jesus oh oh my god
he's gonna toss him aboard it just bit
him and then ran off
he got lucky yeah
he he got lucky that there there's all
those other people in the commotion
and four million people have watched
that so would so as
as people we're ready to see that
four million people have safely watched
that and they're not crying at a center
right now or anything like that
yeah but watching that doesn't seem real
you know we watch that
if you were there in real life like if
you're in that hockey rink
sit in those excellent gold star seats
we're in mexico
uh i think you're in china somewhere
yeah could have made it look like china
this is how this is how it got the guy
or not not this one here
hold on oh no dude wow
coming around here i'm gonna try to
climb the fence
and gotcha wow look at you dragged him
down
oh my god what do you do it just wants
to get out it doesn't know what it wants
right it doesn't know what the [ __ ] it
wants do you jump in the water do you
think they swim yeah
they'll swim oh well that's not good you
think he's bleeding or not oh yeah he's
getting his legs
his arms his legs everything's getting
torn up all that shit's on the ground
that's blood
that's his blood i don't want that i
don't know you definitely don't want
that
i just think we really need to
understand when you thought
you're talking about a large predatory
animal we really
need to understand what [ __ ] we are
the toughest man
that's ever lived is a weak ass [ __ ]
compared to a leopard
just a fact oh jesus look at this one
[ __ ] man who's doing all this
oh i've seen this one this is in india
right yeah it happens in
these areas man these cats they get into
these villages and just start [ __ ]
people
up that's so crazy imagine that and
that's a small animal
compared to a lion